[Music]
look at the taco at the same time similar to the twist
but it's a Mexican version
imagine it as if it were a twist but in a
Mexican version with
mentally Mexican dressings chipotle chili
sauce
[Music]
my name is zacarías galiana I'm like a
taco owner right along with  my
brother andrew galena
the arab tacos are born out of a need
to survive
look at my grandfather he emigrated in 1923 24 from
the border between turkey and iraq
arriving in a strange country and trying to
survive trying to work in
whatever it takes to get ahead see other
migrants  putting a top then
tacos bagdad was founded in 1933 and that's how they
began to make the tacos that are now
known as tacos arabes
look at the process to make the tacos
arabes is to marinate the meat you put it on
a metal base where you start to
put it circularly then on top  you put
onion and then another layer and so you go
layer by layer until you make the
top
from there you take it to the meat apparatus
that ca  mbia well, it's not the same meat a
lot of middle eastern people are muslims or they
can eat pork and here in mexico
like fire to latin america like pork a
lot first they start selling with
corn tortillas and later they
deal with pita bread and then people for  the
psoe but it doesn't have something that stings a
sauce because if they thought of making a
ground chipotle sauce in a molcajete and
with that
the Arab tracks now know it as
sauce for tacuara well all that makes it
different makes it fusion
[Music  ]
then it is very interesting how
when people migrate they carry their customs,
ideas and for years for work and for
many situations they turn it into a
typical dish after a long time
[Music]
this effort of almost 100 years would not be
good it would not be good if it ended
now  It has a history, it already has a tradition, it
already has a long history, right now it's a matter of
making it known
[Music]